>>Rocky Garff: Alright, well let's get started.
I'd like to welcome everyone out to this Leading
at Google series talk. My name's Rocky Garff
I'm a manager in the Media and Platform Solutions
Group here at Google and it's my pleasure
to welcome Liz Wiseman and Greg McKeown, the
authors of the-the Multipliers book.
I actually met Greg a couple years ago when
I moved into his neighborhood and over the
course of the last years I've actually talked
with him and Liz about the ideas in this book.
I've heard them present and I-I really think
it's gonna be interesting for a lot of you
so.
The book came out about a week ago and has
made a run to, it hit the top-top 25 on Amazon
and it's-it's in the top 10 for the leadership
category on Amazon so it's been well received
by the market and just glad to have you guys
here with us today and-and turn the time over
to you.
[applause]
>>Liz Wiseman: Well good afternoon. I am Liz
Wiseman and I'm the author of Multipliers.
I'm the President of a little company called
Wiseman Group, and I'm here with my partner,
Greg McKeown.
The work that we do is really to develop executive
talent, a lot of that here in Silicon Valley,
and to build multiplier leadership around
the world. We're really excited to be here
with you.
Greg is originally from London, England, which
you will hear in a few minutes when you hear
him talk. He came out to the States to go
to business school at Stanford, and he and
I have been working together ever since.
Our remarks today are gonna be focused on
a very simple idea. And the idea is that leaders
can be multipliers. That in their role as
leaders and what they do as a leader they
can make people more capable, more productive,
and we would venture to say smarter.
They can actually be multipliers.
I want to start with a very simple question.
[pause]
What is the fate of the smart and the talented?
What do we do with our smartest, most talented,
most capable people inside organizations.
What do we do with them?
[pause]
Louder.
>>voice in audience: More work.
>>Liz Wiseman: We give 'em more work.
What do we do with the smartest and the most
talented people inside organizations? Quite
often organizations promote them, and they
promote them into management. But the problem
is that many of these leaders have spent years
being reinforced for their own ideas, their
own intelligence, their own capability. And
sometimes these leaders don't look beyond
their own capability to really see and use
the genius that sits on their team.
Leaders who don't make this transition can
end up draining intelligence and capability
from people around them, and they can actually
become what call "diminishers" -- diminishers
of talent and capability.
Now through our research we have seen a different
model of leadership. We've seen a model where
leaders use their smarts and their intellect
to amplify the intelligence of people around
them. And we called these leaders "multipliers."
And what you're gonna see today is what our
research showed that these leaders don't get
a little bit more from the people they work
with, they get vastly more. In fact they get
up to twice the capability from people around
them.
As Greg and I are-are sharing our thoughts
with you today, I'd you to do a couple things.
I'd like you to think about a leader that
you've worked with; someone around whom you
were, you were brilliant, you were capable,
you did your best work, you solved hard, complex
problems.
And then think about another leader around
whom you struggled to do tough things; someone
that made you question your own intelligence.
Maybe around someone that you ended up holding
back, you couldn't give your full capability.
I'd also like you to think about your own
tendencies as a leader. I'd like you to think,
"Are you a multiplier, someone who uses their
intelligence to amplify the intelligence of
others, or are you like many of us who maybe
have a little bit of diminisher in you?" And
I'd like you to think about that as we go
through our remarks.
First let me introduce you to some of these
leaders that we studied. We did a global research
project over two years and these are some
of the leaders that we encountered.
Lutz Ziob, General Manager of Microsoft Learning.
His people say of Lutz, "Lutz creates an environment
where good things happen. He hires great people,
he allows them to make mistakes, and he ferociously
debates the most important decisions with
his management team and his whole organization."
Sue Siegel, former President of Affymetrix,
whose partner says of Sue, she's now a venture
capitalist at Mohr Davidow Ventures. Her partner
says of Sue, "There's a Sue Effect. Everyone
around her grows and companies grow under
her guidance." He says, "I've often wonder
what people are like when they're not around
Sue."
Greg and I went to go interview her. We had
this fabulous interview. We walked out of
the parking lot we're like, "Oh that was a
great question! Oh that was funny! You were
funny! We were so smart!"
[laughter]
And then we're like, "Oh, that wasn't really
us." [laughs] She was smart and we felt brilliant
around Sue. We kinda joked that we got Sued.
But there is this Sue Effect that people are
at their best around Sue Siegel.
Narayana Murthy, former CEO, former Chairman
of the Board of Infosys, one of the jewels
of India, who built a five billion dollar
company, 100,000 people strong, and he built
it on the idea of hiring really smart people,
smarter than himself, and building a management
team that could secede him.
He turned the reins over to Nandan Nilekani
years before it was time for him to step down,
and then Nandan Nilekani did the same thing,
turning the reins over to someone else with
that organization continuing and not skipping
a beat.
KR Sridhar, CEO of Bloom Energy, the innovators
of the Bloom Box which has gotten a lot of
media attention lately, and I guess there
are probably a rack of Bloom Boxes here on
this campus. It's a green tech firm that builds
a clean fuel source.
KR is a brilliant scientist himself. In fact
he literally is a former NASA rocket scientist.
But what he does is he creates an environment
where people can experiment and he creates
an environment of a lot of pressure, but absolutely
no stress.
How do you create an environment with lots
of pressure but no stress? How would you do
that?
[pause]
Lots of pressure, no stress.
He holds people absolutely accountable for
running the experiments -- run the experiments
-- test the science, but he doesn't hold
them accountable for the outcome.
[pause]
And lastly, Bill Campbell. Bill Campbell who
is well known as the former CEO of Intuit,
a fellow who's a former Columbia football
coach turned business executive, who's not
a technologist but has a reputation for working
well with technologists because in his words,
"They have a genius that I don't have." He
sees that genius, he admires that genius,
and he's able to bring out that intelligence
and use it inside the organization.
But maybe not so well known as the former
CEO of Intuit, he has become the coach to
some of Silicon Valley's top executives: Steve
Jobs at Apple, Eric Schmidt here at Google,
and many others at Google and-and other companies.
We're gonna talk a little bit more about Bill
later.
We discovered these multipliers, these people
as Greg and I embarked on our research journey
that started in a very simple observation.
It, so it's an observation based on my 17
years at Oracle where I ran the corporate
university and got to work with the top executive
team.
And Oracle was known for hiring really, really
smart people. And I looked out at this executive
team and they were all brilliant. It's one
they all had in common. But they didn't all
bring out brilliance in people around them.
I noticed that some of these leaders didn't
have what you might consider to be viral or
contagious intelligence. They were brilliant,
but no one else around them got to be so smart.
They had a way of dumbing down people around
them.
Yet other leaders amplified the intelligence
of others and I asked this question, "Why
are we geniuses around some but not around
others?"
As we looked at these two types of leaders,
Greg and I were determined to find out why.
I was out coaching a number of executives
in Silicon Valley, and I saw this pattern
again and again and we wanted to know why.
Why do some leaders amplify intelligence and
others drain it?
Over the course of two years we studied 150
leaders in 35 different companies all across
four continents trying to answer this question.
In pursuit of that, people told us their stories.
They told us about people they worked with
around whom they were smart, they did their
very best work. And they told us about people
that they had worked with where they shut
down and they became incapable.
One of these stories that caught my attention
was told to me by one of my clients, now a
CEO of an Internet startup, but he told this
story about being 18 years old; I call this
story a change in command. It started when
he was 18 years old living in Israel.
And do 18 year olds in Israel do?
[pause]
They go into the military. So Gabi like all
of his peers goes into the military, he goes
into a boot camp program and he is slated
to go in and learn to be a tank commander.
So he's gonna through the tank commander training
program. He does six months of boot camp.
He and two of his fellow soldiers do such
a great job in boot camp that they're actually
tapped on the shoulder and assigned to go
out to real combat duty. So they're deployed
up to the North, they've been training in
the Golan Heights, they're sent up to help
patrol this kind of questionable border between
Israel and Lebanon, and they're gonna be out
in real combat conditions.
In these combat conditions with six months
of boot camp training Gabi does extraordinarily
well. He navigates well, he operates the tank
well, he works well with his fellow soldiers,
he works well with his commanding officers,
he handles the ambiguity and the complexity
of the battlefield extraordinarily well.
Well after three months they go back to Israel,
and they rejoin the group that's just now
finished boot camp. They're now gonna enter
the tank commander training program and rejoin
their peer group. But at the time they do
that and they're sent down to the South of
Israel they experience a change in command.
Now Gabi will go, was going to be performing
and learning under a new commanding officer
whose name was Uval. Now Uval had to leave
the Air Force for health reasons. He comes
in, he's a quick study on tank operations,
he's now a new commanding officer, but he
seems like he has something to prove. And
then specifically he's got something to prove
to Gabi.
[pause]
Gabi does well in the classroom, but every
time he goes out into the field with Uval
at the command he struggles. His team goes
out to perform navigational exercises, they
have to find waypoints and return those way
points back. They start to struggle.
Uval points out all the mistakes, singles
out this group's performance, and they go
from being good navigators to suddenly they're
now returning in the bottom 20 percent.
Gabi does great in the classroom, but every
time he gets in the tank with Uval supervising
him, he starts to struggle. Struggle with
things he had no problem doing out in combat.
Now it won't surprise you when you see how
these-these tanks are set up. So you've got
right here, right there this is the tank commander.
So that's where Gabi sits. This is the very
unfortunate guy whose head is like a foot
out of the tank. There's a, there's a gunner
and there's a navigator, and then seated right
here, right here there's a steel chair bolted
to the top of the tank. That's where the training
officer sits with a clipboard on his thigh
to take notes and document all of the mistakes
that are made.
So this-this guy Uval is literally sitting
10 inches above his head. So for those of
you who think you had a boss who kinda has
hovered over you --
[laughter]
this is nothing. So you can feel this guy
breathing down here.
Well Gabi starts to struggle. Every time he
goes out in the tank with Uval in the chair,
he can't operate. He starts to fail maneuvers,
he doesn't just fail one, he fails two and
three, and quickly Gabi is failing every one
of his tank maneuvers.
So Uval goes to the company commander whose
name is Lior and says, "We have a soldier
that needs to be dismissed from the tank commander
training program."
Well this is a huge deal, this is the end
of his military career. It's not a great way
for a young man to get off to-to start of
his career. But protocol necessitates that
before he can be dismissed from the program,
he needs to perform a single maneuver out
in the field with the company commander, this
young officer named Lior.
Well Gabi's friends are kind of wishing him
luck on this very ill-fated task 'cause they
know he's probably gonna fail at this maneuver
and be booted from the program.
Well Lior takes him and before they get in
the tank Lior kinda walks him up to the tank
and he stops at this model of the battlefield;
it's like a table top about yay high. And
he stops him and he says, "Gabi now what are
you gonna do when we get to this part of the
terrain?" And Gabi goes, "Well I think I kinda
know, I'll probably do this and I'll navigate
here and there." "Now what about if the enemy
comes at you from this angle, what are you
gonna do? What about if the enemy is firing
from over here, what will you do?"
And so Gabi and Lior take a few minutes to
kind of prep. They get into the tank and not
only does Gabi perform that maneuver well
he performs the maneuver perfectly, which
incidentally was the toughest maneuver in
the entire test suite. A maneuver where all
conditions change, nothing can be predicted,
it's nothing but ambiguity and on the fly
kinds of decisions.
They get done, they come down from the tank,
Lior turns to him and he says, "Gabi you are
not dismissed." He stays in the program, graduates
in the top ten percent, goes on to officer
training, graduates again in the ten percent,
and is asked to become a gnan, which is the
Hebrew term for an officer that cultivates
the talent of other officers.
When Gabi told me this story and shared this
experience with me, it reminded me of something
we all know to be true -- that it's often
within change of command comes a change in
capability.
We can be smart and capable and at our best
around some leaders, but yet other leaders
can cause us to doubt ourselves and to hold
back. And in Gabi's case be stupefied with
fear.
[pause]
Why is that? Why would some leaders amplify
intelligence while others drain it? What were
your predictions be?
[pause]
What would you predict?
>>male in audience: If somebody has confidence
in you.
>>Liz Wiseman: If somebody has confidence
in you. What else? Another prediction.
Right here.
>>female in audience: They point, they point
out the things you do well versus the mistakes
that you're making or are about to make.
>>Liz Wiseman: They'd point out what you do
well. Another thought?
>>male in audience: They would encourage you
not dismiss you.
>>Liz Wiseman: Encouraging and not dismissive.
What else would you predict would be why some
leaders amplify intelligence in others?
In the back.
>>male in audience: People who are self conscious
[unintelligible]other than thinking about
yourself.
>>Liz Wiseman: People who are self conscious
don't perform well so they take that extreme
orientation off of you. Okay.
Here's, we're gonna do a little exercise.
I want you to think about two different leaders
that you've worked for, one around, one who
was a diminisher to you, one who was a multiplier.
You've got a piece of paper and there's a
number of pencil, pens and pencils down there.
I want you to take two minutes and consider
a diminisher, what did they do? Just write
down one thing that they did that was characteristic
of their leadership approach. How did they
manage?
And we want you to write down something that
the multiplier did. Okay.
Then a little tougher question, which was
really the backbone of our research: what
percentage of your capability did each of
these leaders get? Okay.
This is not how hard were you working. It's
with what you know, your capability, your
skills, what you had to offer, how much of
that did they really get from you? Okay. A
percentage, somewhere between 1 and 100, 100
is they got everything from you. Okay.
I want you to take minute or two to do that
and we're gonna ask to hear from a few of
you.
[pause]
Okay. We wanna hear from a few of you. Who's
got one for me? I'll come find you.
Right here, Yvonne.
>>Yvonne: Okay. So the diminisher, what they
did was they took credit for my work and limited
my exposure. The percentage of the capability
was 70 percent.
The multiplier put me in stretch spots and
believed in me --
>>Liz Wiseman: Okay.
>>Yvonne: and got 110.
>>Liz Wiseman: So the mul, diminisher took
credit, multiplier believed in you, 70 percent
and a 110 percent.
Okay I'm gonna need some people who are gonna
help me with the math on this.
Now we did, we're gonna do a little bit of
informal research. I need two people who are
fast on the calculator.
[pause]
Got their laptops up who can do this is like
a moment's notice. Okay I a couple-couple
math people. I'd ask Greg to do it but he
claims to not be very good at math.
[pause]
Anyone? Anyone fast on the math?
Because you are first to offer you can add
up the multiplier scores. And right here I'm
gonna ask you add up the diminisher scores.
We have 70 and we have 110. Right over here.
Okay.
You're multiplier.
>>male in audience: So my multiplier expressed
interest and encouragement, celebrated victories.
>>Liz Wiseman: Okay.
>>male in audience: And the diminisher doubted
my capabilities, dismissed accomplishments.
>>Liz Wiseman: Okay diminisher doubted, multiplier
expressed -
>>male in audience: Interest and encouragement.
>>Liz Wiseman: interest and encouragement
and the numbers are diminisher?
>>male in audience: Forty.
>>Liz Wiseman: Got forty percent. And the
multiplier got?
>>male in audience: Ninety.
>>Liz Wiseman: Ninety percent. Okay. Another
one from over here.
Right here.
Start with your multiplier.
>>male in audience: Multiplier believed in
me, trusted me, left me alone to do the work
and the diminisher only, kind of like only
let, let their opinions be counted and put
myself, put the whole group down and didn't
listen to anybody.
>>Liz Wiseman: Yeah. Did you hear that? The
multiplier trusted me and left me alone to
do my work. It's one of the big things we
found. These people give others space. They
give 'em a ton of space. They give 'em hard
things and they leave them alone. Okay.
Multiplier got?
>>male in audience: I mean I said 120 percent
because it made me smarter, hundred doesn't
make, and the diminisher 10 percent.
>>Liz Wiseman: Okay, multiplier 120, diminisher
10. Okay.
Who else has got numbers between one, zero
and 100 for me?
Thank you. He's telling us an important story.
We're gonna get back to this.
Who else? I need one or two more.
[pause]
Over here, thank you.
Start with your multiplier.
>>male in audience: The multiplier explained
the needs and the diminisher, and the diminisher
assigned tasks.
>>Liz Wiseman: Okay one explains the need,
they explain the why. It's a big part of what
multipliers do is they explain the why behind
the work 'cause when people tell us why, we
can be really smart. The diminisher assigned
the tasks.
Give us your numbers, multiplier?
>>male in audience: A hundred percent.
>>Liz Wiseman: A hundred percent.
Did you have 110 written down?
>>male in audience: I did not.
>>Liz Wiseman: You did not, okay. [laughs]
And the diminisher?
>>male in audience: Twenty five.
>>Liz Wiseman: Twenty five. Okay. Up here,
your multiplier and then diminisher.
>>male in audience: The multiplier created
a lot of excitement about the project whereas
the diminisher really seemed kind of bored
with the, my work and with what the group
was doing.
>>Liz Wiseman: Yeah. So excitement on the
multiplier, boredom on the diminisher.
And your numbers are for the multiplier?
>>male in audience: One hundred.
>>Liz Wiseman: One hundred.
>>male in audience: Sixty-six.
>>Liz Wiseman: And sixty-six. Okay.
I want just a few more shout outs on these
numbers. Let's take this group kind of right
here. Give me your number on your multipliers.
>>female in audience: Eighty-five.
>>Liz Wiseman: Eighty-five.
>>male in audience: A hundred.
>>Liz Wiseman: A hundred.
>>male in audience: Ninety.
>>Liz Wiseman: Ninety. And?
>>Liz Wiseman: Ninety.
Okay, one more.
>>male in audience: Also ninety.
>>Liz Wiseman: Also ninety. Okay.
How 'bout diminishers? Someone do some shout
outs of your diminishers.
>>male in audience: [unintelligible]
>>Liz Wiseman: Ten percent. Ten percent of
what he was able to give.
>>male in audience: Forty.
>>Liz Wiseman: Forty.
>>female in audience: Seventy.
>>Liz Wiseman: Seventy.
>>male in audience: Eighty-five.
>>Liz Wiseman: Eighty-five.
>>female in audience: Fifty.
>>Liz Wiseman: Fifty percent.
[pause]
>>male in audience: Ten.
>>Liz Wiseman: Ten percent. Okay.
How 'bout one more? A shout out. In the back.
>>male in audience: Forty.
>>Liz Wiseman: Forty percent. Okay.
Now our math geniuses here are gonna be adding
that up as we look at this. We found very
consistently these multipliers and diminishers
do different things. When you've got these
numbers let us know. Let me know.
Multiplier?
>>male in audience: Do you want a sum?
>>Liz Wiseman: I want an average. I did not
explain that well. I want an average.
Okay.
[pause]
Here's what we found in our research and Greg
is gonna take you through the-the-the nuts
and bolts of our finding. We found that these
multipliers really get more from people, and
they do things differently.
Diminishers tend to be geniuses; people who
find strength in their own intelligence. It's
what they rely on, they rely on their own
intelligence to get their job done.
Multipliers tend to be genius makers. They
themselves might be brilliant and capable,
but they see their role as a leader as to
create and amplify intelligence around them.
[pause]
Do we have our numbers?
>>male in audience: Yes.
>>Liz Wiseman: Average for our diminishers?
>>male in audience: Forty-three.
>>Liz Wiseman: Forty-three percent. And do
we have an average for our multiplier?
>>male in audience: Not yet.
>>Liz Wiseman: Not yet. Okay.
Greg, Greg will query it from you.
[pause]
>>Greg McKeown: So what did we find? We found
that diminishers and multipliers actually
do a lot of things the same, really similar.
But they do a few things really differently
that makes a really big difference.
So what is the most important difference we
found? It was the assumptions that they held.
So whereas diminishers seemed to have this
sense of scarcity around intelligence, that
people will never be able to figure this out
without me. It's like one of the executives
that confessed after a meeting this 4,000
engineers in his group he says, "There's just
one or two people that I find worth listening
to around here. What do you need from all
the rest of them, these people they're just
not smart enough for me to really take them
seriously."
Contrast that with multipliers who have this
sense of abundance that it's not you're either
smart or you're dumb, it's about in what way
are you smart. A sense of abundance in intelligence
and capability, particularly this idea that
people are smart and they'll figure this out.
Give them a chance, they'll work it out. Show
them what the problem is, they'll work it
out. Give them that space.
These assumptions lead to five particular
differences between diminishers and multipliers.
First of all, diminishers tended to work as
empire builders so they were more interested
in building their empires than they were in
building other people's careers. So as an
example of this you could compare two Stanford
professors -- one who was so interested in
his own thinking, his own research that he's
busy writing his blogs and writing his next
paper and so on, that the people underneath
said, "I just never even get to see him. I
mean he's brilliant, yes everyone knows that,
but I just get no-no time, no face time, no-no
opportunity."
Contrast this with the late Rajeev Motwani,
who of course was Sergey and Larry's advisor
at Stanford. Sergey Brin wrote that, "When
his interest turned to data mining Rajeev,
who had specialized in the field, helped to
coordinate a regular meeting group on the
subject.
Later when Larry and I began to work together
on the research that would lead to Google,
Rajeev was there to support us, guide us through
challenges both technical and organizational.
Eventually as Google emerged from Stanford,
Rajeev remained a friend and advisor, as he
has with many people and start ups since."
You just think of what happened because this
multiplier Motwani was not obsessed with his
own knowledge and his own agenda, that he
could be aware of the knowledge and insight
and interest and intelligence in his students.
And of course every one of us is impacted
by his genius. He wasn't a genius, he was
a genius maker. He wasn't obsessed with his
own intellectual empire but in really accelerating
the careers in the people around him.
Secondly, we found that diminishers tended
to be tyrants, while multipliers tended to
be liberators. It's just the difference between
creating a tense climate that stifles people
and an intense climate that draws out people's
very best and boldest thinking.
Third, we found that diminishers tended to
be know-it-alls. I mean they just, just thought
that what they knew was the most important
thing, they had to be the smartest person
in the room versus multipliers who are challengers.
We heard about that, these stretch assignments
that really push people beyond what they know
how to do. It's really just the difference
between thinking that your job is to have
the right answer versus thinking that your
job is to have the right question. It's a
big orientation difference.
Fourth, diminishers tended to be decision
makers. The idea is they thought, "Well listen
if I could just make the decision fast enough
then we'll quickly get on to being able to
execute this, so I'll just make all the decisions
fast, fast, fast." They'll go and do it.
They thought that they could skip the debate,
somehow we'll just miss that and then we'll
just get on to execution. But what we learned
as we studied this is that you can't just
skip debate, you can't choose if debate happens,
you all know this is true. You go to a meeting
and nobody really talks about it and the real
meeting happens after the meeting has taken
place. The debate happens.
What multipliers learn is that you just have
to figure out when to do it, how to do it,
so that it can actually help make a really
smart decision, drive a sound decision. And
this is what we found. They were debate makers,
they would frame how those decisions were
made and how the debate took place.
And fifth, they were, the difference between
being a micromanager, think of one manager
we studied who at two o'clock everyday would
walk around the cubicles just to see what
was on someone's screen, "What are they doing?
I gotta be here, they won't get on with work
if I'm not around hovering there."
And another multiplier the, which at the time
John Chambers hired his first VP and he said,
"Listen," he said, "this is how it's gonna
work from here on out. You're gonna be in
charge of this. Everything in your area 51
percent, I'm in charge 49 percent. You come
to me, I'll advise you, I want to have input,
but you own this." And so he had this sense
of ownership that he was now really in charge,
and he shifted the burden of thinking from
himself onto his team.
And so of course what does this lead to? They
get a lot more capability and intelligence
out of their people. Let's talk about how
much more. What did you get here?
>>male in audience: Ninety-eight percent.
>>Greg McKeown: Ninety-eight percent. What
did you say?
>>male in audience: Forty-three percent.
>>Greg McKeown: Forty-three to ninety-eight.
Doesn't take a math genius to work out the
approximate ratio is? Two X.
If you're a diminisher you tend to get about
50 percent of the intelligent, intelligence
that's available as an average. As a multiplier
you get twice that capability, you get everything.
And these 110 and 120s originally the idea
was, "Well this is kind of off the chart.
This is just an outline, let's not use it."
But then after a time when we talked to people
and really asked them they said, "No, I got
smarter." Intelligence could be grown, could
be expanded.
What are the implications of this to organizations?
First, diminishers are expensive. I mean they
take twice the resources to get the same job
done. Twice the resources at least to get
the same intellectual brain trust. For once
the CFO and the HR executive agree. This is
a kind of leader that we want inside of organizations.
And the second implication is the other side
of the same point which is that multipliers
get so much more brain power from their people
that they essentially doubled the intellectual
workforce for free.
[pause]
A question was put by a-a-an article that
was published in United Arab Emirates recently,
"What kind of leader are you?" What kind are
you? What kind am I? Diminisher, multiplier?
And then the second question, "What kind of
leader do you aspire to be?"
[pause]
The activist and lead singer for U2, Bono,
said, "It has been said that after meeting
the great British Prime Minister William Ewart
Gladstone, you left feel-feeling that you
had met the smartest person in the world,
but after meeting his rival Benjamin Disraeli,
you left thinking you were the smartest person."
This seems to us to be a very succinct synopsis
of the contrast between these two types of
leaders and their approach.
[pause]
>>Liz Wiseman: So we ask you to reflect for
a just a few minutes on what kind of leader
do you want to be? A genius or a genius maker?
One rooted in his or her own capabilities,
the center of attention, and perhaps the limiting
force for the growth of your team or one who
unleashes genius inside your or-organization?
Someone who leads an army of geniuses.
[pause]
In a recent Tweet this was I think from-from
was last week one of the-the people who got
an early copy of the book, a blogger said,
"The person sitting at the apex of the intelligence
hierarchy is the genius maker, not the genius."
That was his take away in these ideas. It's
at the apex of the genius hierarchy.
We'd like to kind of move to a thought around
how do you become a multiplier? Many of us
are already there, but many of us probably
have some seeds of diminisher in our leadership
based on how we kinda have grown up in our
career.
Can you become a multiplier? And how do you
become one?
I'd like to just start with Bill Campbell
as an example. I mentioned Bill Campbell,
multiplier, CEO of Intuit, and now coach to
Steve Jobs, Eric Schmidt, Larry, Sergey, but
he didn't start out this way. When we went
to interview Bill Campbell someone said, "Oh
Liz you need to talk to Bill Campbell. He's
a massive multiplier."
So I went down, Greg and I went down, we sat
with him in his office and he said, "Oh no.
I'm not a multiplier. Well maybe now, but
I didn't start this way." He said, "Let me
tell you how I started my career. I began
my career as a diminisher. I came outta Columbia,
I was the head football coach, I was all about
telling people what to do. I was calling all
the plays.
I went to work for Kodak as a marketing manager.
I bossed everyone around. I told people what
to do. When the sales people didn't have their
sales plans right, I just rewrote 'em for
'em."
He then went to Apple, worked under John Sculley,
was taught that his job was to be a micromanager,
to know every detail, and to check on every
detail in the people around him.
He started to grow out of this, he started
Claris, he was doing a good job, but then
one day someone came to him and they said,
"Bill, you're back to your old ways. You're
telling everyone what to do, you're bossing
us around. We can't do our work." This was
Donna Dubinsky who went on to then head Palm
and she said, "Bill, we need some space. We
came here because we believe in you, but you're
telling everyone to do, like the leash. [laughs]
It's like a choke hold on the leash. We need
more space."
And this little near mutiny was a wakeup call
for Bill and he said, "I realize that now
in your terms I was a diminisher."
He learned to really see and utilize the pep-the
intelligence in people around him. He went
on to be CEO of Inuit. And then not only is
he a multiplier today, he's what we call a
"multiplier of multipliers." He's been the
one to help Jeffery Bezos figure out how to
scale Amazon. Marc Andreessen, Ben Horowitz,
the team here at Google and at Apple; he is
the one that helps these technologists figure
out how to lead in a way that harnesses all
the intelligence available to them in their
organization.
Now one can pursue the path of Bill Campbell
and take 20, 25, maybe 30 years to make this
journey. We asked the question, "Can this
be accelerated?"
Now Greg and I admit that in our study, in
our research of 150 leaders we studied the
extremes. We studied the extreme diminisher,
the extreme multiplier. The kind of people
you thought about when we asked you to identify
two leaders. But in reality there's a bell
curve between this and most of us don't sit
at these polar extremes. There's a few people
here, we love 'em, we study them, we wrote
about them. We wrote about a lot of these
folks too. We took their names out of the
book [laughs] kinda the witness protection
program.
But most of us sit right here in the middle
and the most interesting group from our perspective
is not the raging diminisher, it's the accidental
diminisher. It's the-the good leader, the
good manager who wants to do a good job, but
is following popular management practice,
following what they see, and they might accidentally
be diminishing people around them.
What are some ways that you might accidentally
be diminishing people around you?
[pause]
Something you might do?
How 'bout visionaries. Big thinkers, do we
have any big thinkers in here? Sometimes people
can be such big thinkers that they don't leave
space for anyone else.
Is there anyone here who has the gift of gab?
[pause]
Sometimes our enthusiasm, how 'bout idea people?
People who are like ideas just come to you
like this? When you come into work every day
with a new idea what does it do to people
around you?
[pause]
Have you ever had a boss who came into work
every day with, "Oh, let's try this. Let's
consider this. What about this?" What does
that boss think he or she is doing by spouting
out these ideas? What's their intention?
They're inspiring people 'cause we've talked
to these people. "I'm inspiring people. I'm
stimulating innovation." What are they really
doing to their organization?
>>male in audience: [unintelligible]daily
basis.
>>Liz Wiseman: They're changing direction
on a daily basis and you run and follow them,
and then there's a new idea and then you run
this way, and then you go this way, and you
spend all of your mental energy chasing these
people around in circles. What else do they
do?
>>voice in audience: [unintelligible]
>>Liz Wiseman: Okay. How about answer guys?
Who are people who are just quick with an
answer? Can solve a problem fast in their
head and pretty quick with that answer?
[pause]
Okay. I'm kinda one. I admit it. A little
bit of an answer guy. When you're quick with
an answer what does it do to the people around
you?
>>male in audience: It keeps them from responding.
>>Liz Wiseman: It keeps them responding?
>>male in audience: From responding.
>>Liz Wiseman: It keeps them from responding,
right.
If I work with someone who's fast with an
answer what do I do when there's a question?
>>female in audience: You go to them [unintelligible]
>>Liz Wiseman: I let them answer it. I've
think, "You know what?" And I've done this,
and the years I spent at Oracle was very much
like I'm-I'm sure many of you feel here. I
work with geniuses. And sometimes we defer,
we defer to people who are fast with an answer.
As Greg said these ideas are kind of getting
out there. We're interested to hear what people
around the world are saying about them.
This is from a-a paper in-in Nairobi saying,
"What are, these, yes we understand there
are multipliers and diminishers, but how do
you become a multiplier? Are there some simple
ways to do that?"
And what Greg and I would like to do is leave
you with one very simple idea. And that is
to move from answers to questions. Now most
of us here, particularly technologists, their
value early in their career coming out of
school, early in the career of a technologist
is to have the answers. It's what people were
hired for.
But the value of having those answers diminishes
over time. Some leaders never figure this
out. They don't figure out that their role
as a leader is less about having answers,
particularly as they lead large organizations
where they can't know everything. But they
need to add a layer, a growing layer of having
the right questions.
And truly as we've studied executives -- the
best executives have the right questions not
the right answers.
So if you're looking for a simple starting
point to leading more like a multiplier, it's
learn to think in questions. Use your intellect
and your smarts to formulate hard questions
that cause other people to stop and to think
and then to respond. Shift the burden of thinking
from you as the leader to find the answers
and shift that burden out into your organization,
so your organization has permission to think.
Kind of a final thought we would leave you
with: how many people here saw the documentary
Man On Wire? Yeah. Couple of people here.
It chronicles Frenchman Philippe Petit, his
outrageous act of illegally stringing a cable
across the then standing World Trade towers
back in 1974; stringing this cable across
140 foot expanse between the towers, 100,
no 1,400 feet up in the air, no nets, no harnesses,
just a tightrope artist and his pole.
Now the image that most people remember is
this image; the man out on the wire by himself
with no support up in the air. And what did
he do once he got out on that wire? Did he
just kinda scurry across and declare victory?
What did he do?
>>voice in audience: [unintelligible] dance.
>>Liz Wiseman: He danced. He like kinda rolled
around on the wire; he laid down. He played,
he was out there for like a half an hour,
he was playing and having fun because once
he got out on that wire he knew what to do.
Okay.
Now that's what most people remember. But
I saw him on Colbert actually, and this is
what I remember. This is the image that stands
out in my mind. This is the image of him taking
a single step.
And I was so struck by what he said, he, I
think it was Colbert that said, "Wh-what caused
you to do this thing? What caused you to go
out on the wire?" He goes, "You know being
out on the wire wasn't hard." He said, "What
was hard was the moment of truth when I stood
there on the building on the edge of the building
with one foot anchored safely to the building
and the other foot out on the wire."
He said, "I had to make a decision: do I shift
my weight from the foot that's anchored to
the building and do I shift my weight out
on that wire?" He said, "Something I could
not resist called me out on that wire, and
I shifted my weight."
So perhaps at the conclusion of our remarks
you think, "You know I'm pretty comfortable
in how I lead." You might be comfortably standing
on that building, but perhaps you're intrigued
with this idea that you can be a multiplier
and that you might be able to get more from
other people and create for them an exhilarating
experience. And perhaps you've got that one
foot out on the wire.
Imagine what you could do if you had double
the brain power inside your organization.
What hard problems could you solve? What opportunities
could be met? What would be possible? What
could a team of smart, talented people do
if they were operating at 100 percent brainpower?
So as you think of that, we simply ask you
the question: will you shift your weight and
lead more like a multiplier?
Thank you for having Greg and me here at Google.
Thank you.
[applause]
Are there any questions? I know people probably
have to go to meetings, but we are very happy
to hear comments, questions --
[pause]
I'll bring the microphone to you if you would
like.
>>male in audience: I'd like to hear what
you guys think about Steve Jobs. Is he a diminisher
or a multiplier?
>>Liz Wiseman: You know Greg I was gonna hand
the mic to you on the first question, do want
me to take it or do you want it?
>>Greg McKeown: Go ahead.
>>Liz Wiseman: [laughs]
[laughter]
We get this question just about everywhere
we go, Steve Jobs. If someone were just looking
at what is publicly reported and the sort
of persona of Steve Jobs, you might conclude
that Steve has some characteristics of a diminisher.
But when you talk to people who work for him,
you will probably conclude that Steve is brilliantly
a multiplier in a small circle inside of Apple
and with a certain set of people.
And what Steve has figured out is he has,
he's absolutely a multiplier to those people.
I've talked to a number of 'em who work for
him that say, "I do my best work around Steve."
I don't think he's figured out how to do this
broadly across his organization to be frank,
but what he's done is he has brilliantly hired
Tim Cook who's the COO, and he was the interim
CEO when Steve was out ill. And Tim is absolutely
a multiplier who thinks scale.
So I think Steve balances himself well. That's
my opinion on it.
Other questions?
[pause]
Go right to the jugular with the Steve Jobs
question.
[laughter]
I like that one.
[pause]
Or just thoughts, yeah.
>>male in audience: So you're categorizing
like multipliers and diminishers, what about
the people who are in the middle like you
were talkin' about, like who are diminishers
in one factor and multipliers in a different
situation? How do you characterize, like when
do you find out what-what situation you are
multiplier and diminisher in?
>>Greg McKeown: Yeah, so I think the question
is how do you assess where you are on this
continuum? We-we have three different assessments
you can do. There's one that's actually free
online, it's called multipliersquiz.com, multipliersquiz.com.
It's ten questions. It'll be focused directly
at this question, which we think is a really
great question because most of us fall in
between somewhere.
So you can't just say, "Well, hey listen I'm
not one of these tyrants so therefore it doesn't
apply." Most of us are in the middle. We mean
to access everything, but we accidentally
don't. So this is where I would begin. That'd
be my suggestion, multipliersquiz.com. There
are more advanced assessments for people that
are interested in going a bit further than
that.
Thank you.
What other questions do you have?
[pause]
>>male in audience: I know that this isn't
exactly the direct focus of what your book
is, but you-you noted that a lot of times
leaders remember in the past that they had
to provide all the answers, and then they
don't really have that much, I mean they have
a lot of difficulty transitioning over to
the questions? So then what happens, or I
don't know if you guys know what happens to
the people who start out with all the questions
and then move, and then try to move up. Like
how-how do they go ahead with that?
Has you, have you had like any experiences
of leaders who have been multipliers from
the start?
>>Liz Wiseman: From the start? [unintelligible]
[pause]
>>Greg McKeown: So I think you're question
is about somebody that makes the other transition,
goes from multiplier to --
>>male in audience: No if they start out a
multiplier what would they do?
>>Liz Wiseman: Yeah, I think the question
is what about leaders who start asking those
questions early on. And now that you've asked
that it does make me think of-of people who
start out, they may start out in large corporations,
but I think these are people who come into
their work with an entrepreneurial mindset
and I think if you actually, I can't claim
to have studied this, but if you study great
entrepreneurs they very early in their career
start asking hard questions. They may have
brilliant technical know-how, but they couple
it with asking about what's possible. And
I think if you study a lot of the large companies
here and the most innovative companies in
the Valley, you'll see that these are people
who early, early in their career questioned
assumptions, asked what was possible, and
really challenged the status quo. And I think
they think in terms of questions. But they
add that on top of like deep technical know-how.
Okay, we'll go here and then over --
>>male in audience: So I started to think
your talk about multipliers in particular,
I was reminded of what I read in the book
Built to Last by Jerry Porras and others.
And one of the important characteristics they
had there was it was I'll paraphrase it as
lack of ego.
I mean they were thinking about the organization
building it. Although they were not tough
but they didn't have that ego gratification,
that drive to promote themselves. Is that
kind of a crucial characteristic, that's kind
of why I think the question about Steve Jobs
came up because one doesn't associate less
ego with Steve Jobs.
[pause]
>>Greg McKeown: Yeah, I mean this question
when-when we were studying this phenomenon
we were looking for something very complex
in a way that would distinguish the two groups
of people.
But in the end we started finding ourselves
increasingly saying, "No part of the difference
may be a core difference is that they just
don't center on themselves." So they just
aren't so obsessed with having to prove that
they're the smartest person; that they just
are able to see other people around them.
So instead of having to get their own career
moving they just go, "Oh, I'm okay, I'm smart,
I'm gonna figure this stuff out. I'll be promoted.
No worries about that. Let me just focus on
other people," did seem to be one of the critical
differences.
[pause]
>>Liz Wiseman: Let me add to what Greg said.
One of the concerns that we had is that people
might read this book or there's a, there's
a Harvard Business Review article, we brought
a few copies for anyone who wants that, that
they might take these ideas at a cursory level
and they might come to the conclusion that
says, "For me to be a multiplier I can't be
the smart one. I have to kind of recede into
the background. I have to be the guy with
the questions." And it's absolutely not the
case.
What multipliers do is they use all of their
own intelligence too. They know that their
brain power is important so they in some ways
-- you could look at it as a lack of ego
or you could look at the flip side of that
coin which is they have utter confidence in
their own capability and their own intelligence.
They use it, they use it to frame questions
and to frame challenges and know the hard
things to ask and to know what's technically
possible and impossible. So they're using
all of their brainpower but they have enough
confidence that they don't limit the group
to that. They use their brainpower in full
to spark intelligence in people around them.
Any other questions or comments? And a comment
is as great as a question.
>>male in audience: In thinking about this
idea of the multipliers of multipliers, it
seems like you would wind up with clusters
of multipliers and in a, in a sense I think
I wouldn't if I was working for a diminisher
I would become a diminisher myself. So do
you find these kinds of clusters of orgs that
are multiplier culture-wise and diminisher
culture-wise?
>>Liz Wiseman: Yeah the question is do we
find that these multipliers cluster together?
We certainly find that people flock to work
for multipliers. And-and I absolutely believe
I think most people who study leadership would
say that it does trickle down that people
emulate what they see.
We know for a, this is what we know for a
fact is that a lot of well intended leaders
have the heart of a multiplier and even maybe
like the mind and the heart of a multiplier,
but they've worked for a diminisher for so
long or they've worked in a diminishing culture
for so long that they've lost their way and
they become what Greg and I call "this accidental
diminisher."
So we know that diminisher leadership breeds
diminishers. But it breeds accidental diminishers
not the raging kind.
We haven't yet studied like do multipliers
sort of like breed other multipliers. We know
people flock to them.
Greg any other thoughts on that?
If not, there's another question.
[pause]
>>male in audience: I have what might be a
related question. You mentioned a bell curve,
did your research show a bell curve or is
that an assumption? Because I, sometimes I
think it might be worse than that.
[laughter]
[pause]
>>Greg McKeown: Yeah, we-we didn't study it
in terms of a bell curve. It is an assumption.
We don't know where the-the-the gravity pull
really lies on this. It's an interesting question
though. We imagined there'd be further research
that could be done.
Thank you.
>>Liz Wiseman: We certainly know it's a spectrum
and we assume its bell curve like, but it's
an assumption.
>>Greg McKeown: Any final questions here?
[pause]
Thank you.
>>male in audience: We don't always get to
be leaders. In every group there's usually
one at least a minority of the group would
be leaders and most of them would be following
a leader, and every question asked would eventually
have to be answered by someone, but you seem
to be saying, "Okay we should think in questions
and not in answers then."
I mean, I-I-I see, I see something not coming
together here like eventually who is to answer
the questions and are we, are we not valuing
those who are answering the questions enough?
[pause]
>>Liz Wiseman: So the question is, is if we
breed multipliers, do we end up with a lot
of people who ask questions but no one that
answers them? And I don't think so because
multipliers they're asking that question wanting
an answer, and they're gonna ask it in a way
that people, people are, it's a natural gravitational
pull to wanna be knowledgeable and to wanna
be smart and I think you might be surprised
that you can actually serve as a multiplier
as a direct boss, you can do it as a peer,
you can do as a so-called subordinate. You
can be a multiplier to your boss. And I think
you'll find that if you ask those questions
people will step in to answer them.
I think one of the things we found is that
these multipliers create this space, and it's
almost this uncomfortable space. They ask
hard questions, they give big challenges,
and they create this vacuum that people have
to close. People have to find answers to these
questions.
Any other final comments?
Yes.
[pause]
>>male in audience: Can everyone become a
multiplier or is aren't there people who cannot
be multipliers just like the great question
can everyone, anyone become a leader?
[pause]
>>Greg McKeown: Yeah, the question is, is,
can everyone really make this transition?
And our position on this is that there may
be a few people who are so entrenched and
rewarded for their diminisher approaches or
are so blind to their diminisher approaches
that they just are really not ever likely
to make that transition, but we think it's
very few and far between.
So there was a, one of the people that we've
worked with who was known as an arch diminisher.
His organization after he went through sort
of a six month, twelve month process of really
understanding what was going on, he moved
to a different company and there with those
new assumptions and approaches was known as
a multiplier. So it was a shift that really
did happen for this individual.
So we believe anecdotally that there may be
a few people that can't, but they're few and
far between.
Thank you.
>>Liz Wiseman: It really is. Multiplier leadership
is something that can be learned, you can
do it from all angles whether you're in a
formal management job and, or whether you
the most junior person on the team. So everyone
can lead like a multiplier. We encourage you
to think about ways that you might do more.
We've got resources here to support you.
Greg and I would like to thank you for having
us here. It's wonderful to be down here. We
love coming to the campus. I love everything
about it except the Aloe water, so thank you
very much for having us.
[applause]